[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء اقدمها لكم ميسون ويهد نبدا
بالعناوين
هجوم صاروخي من لبنان على اسرائيل نتانيا
هو يحمل حماس المسؤوليه ويبحثوا مع الجيش
طريقه الرد
[موسيقى]
لبنان يدعو المجتمع الدولي لوقف ايه صعيد
اسرائيلي ويبدي استعداده للتهدئه عبر
اليونيفلد
يوم ساخن في فرنسا الاحتجاجات تتحول
الاشتباكات وعمليات تخريب ردا على قانون
التقاعد
[تصفيق]
رغم دعوات حضره تيك توك يحقق ارباحا
اعلانيه عاليه من كبرى الشركات في امريكا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم عشرات الصواريخ انطلقت بشكل
مفاجئ من الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه
اسرائيل مشهد متوتر غاب قليلا ومن ثم عاد
الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن استعداده لمواجهه
اي تهديد فيما يدرس الان للتانياهو الذي
حمل حماس المسؤوليه مع رئاسه الاركان
طريقه الرد متواعدا بانها ستكون قاسيه
لبنان بدوره دعا المجتمع الدولي الى منع
تل ابيب من التصعيد وابدا استعداده
للتهدئه ولكن بشرط ان يكون ذلك عبر قنوات
اليونيفال بالقوات اليونيفيل اما في ردود
الفعل الدوليه اعلنت واشنطن ان حالفتها
اسرائيل لها الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد
الصواريخ التي تطلق عليها من لبنان
ندين اطلاق الصواريخ من لبنان وغزه على
اسرائيل التزامنا بامن اسرائيل صارم
ونعترف بحقها المشروع في الدفاع عن نفسها
ضد جميع اشكال العدوان
[موسيقى]
يا جماعه بيطلع الصواريخ من عنا شايفين
شايفين
[موسيقى]
ليكون من وين عم يطلعوا الصواريخ
قال الجيش اللبناني انه عثر على منصات
صواريخ وعدد من الصواريخ المعدله للاطلاق
في محيط بلدتي والقليله جنوبي لبنان ويجري
العمل على تفكيكها كما اكد الجيش اللبناني
انه يسير دوريات مكثفه في الجنوب بالتعاون
مع قوه اليونيفيلد
بدورها طالبت قوه الامم المتحده المؤقته
في لبنان اليونيفيل جميع الاطراف باتخاذ
اجراءات لخفض التصعيد على الحدود بين
لبنان واسرائيل وقالت ان الوضع الراهن في
جنوب لبنان خطير جدا كما دعت جميع الاطراف
الى تجنب التصعيد واكدت انها على تواصل مع
الجانبين الاسرائيلي واللبناني لبحث
التطورات
افاد مراسل العربيه باطلاق نحو 30 صاروخا
من لبنان على الاراضي الاسرائيليه فيما
اشارت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه الى اغلاق
المعابر من حيفا حتى الحدود مع لبنان
واغلاق المجال الجوي في شمال اسرائيل بعد
ان تصدت الدفاعات الجويه الاسرائيليه لعدد
من الصواريخ
من الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه ينضم
الينا زياد حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه في
القدس زياد اهلا بك معنا انت حيث انت
تتواجد الان منذ قليل كان سقط بعض قذائف
الهاون هل يمكن ان تطلعنا على الوضع
الميداني الان والان ايضا خبر عاجل على
شاشه العربيه بان الاجتماع الامني بعد
قليل لحكومه نتانياهو
هذا صحيح جدا ميسون اتضح لاحقا بانها لم
تكن قذائف موردر وانما صواريخ عيار 107
مليمتر صواريخ كتيوشه صغيره اطلقت من بعد
نحو عشره كيلو مترات عن حيث اقف على من
المنطقه الحدوديه سقطت في منطقه هنا في
الخلف عمليا في الاراضي الزراعيه
الملاصقه للسياج الامني على الحدود مع
لبنان بعد ربع ساعه تقريبا تبدا يبدا
اجتماع الحكومه الامنيه المصغره
الاسرائيليه
و يدرس اساسا البحث في سيدراس اساسا الرد
الاسرائيلي المتوقع بعد ان كانت هناك
مشاورات رئيسها نتنياهو ورئيسها في موقع
اخر ايضا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي مع قاده
الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه الذين وضعوا توصيه
للحكومه الامنيه المصغره عليها ان تتخذ
هذا القرار حاليا التوقعات ميسون تذهب في
اطار ما نتحدث عنه منذ ساعات الظهيره
بمعنى اسرائيل شخصت بالنسبه لها بان حماس
هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق صواريخ من الجبهه
هنا اللبنانيه وكذا ايضا من قطاع غزه رغم
انها حملت لبنان المسؤوليه بطبيعه الحال
التوقعات ان يكون هناك قصف ربما محدود في
جنوب لبنان لبعض المواقع ولكن اساسا قصف
على قطاع غزه وربما حتى قصف في سوريا
لاحقا على مواقع تابعه لحزب الله ربما
هناك الجغرافيا المريحه اكثر التي لا تشعل
حروبا عندما تشهد تصعيدا يعني زياد من
خلال متابعتك وخاصه قراءتك للبيانات
الاسرائيليه هل من الممكن ان نستشف بان
الامور ايله الى تصعيد محدود
هذا وارد جدا
وبطبيعه الحال لن يكون في المرات الماضيه
ميسون اعطيك مثالا عام 2021 في رمضان ثلاث
مرات اطلقت صواريخ من لبنان
وعمليا بعد اقل من نصف ساعه كان هناك رد
اسرائيلي اولي باطلاق قذائف مدفعيه حتى
هذا الرد غاب هذه المره عن المشهد لم تطلق
اسرائيل قذائف مدفعيه تجاه الاراضي
اللبنانيه وهي تدرس بحذر الان امكانيه
ردها عمليا المعضله الاسرائيليه وفق
مراقبين باتت واضحه ان ان لم ترد او ذهبت
الى رد محدود جدا عمليا هذا يعني بان
معادله الرضع شبه المنهاره قد تكون انتهت
على هذه الجبهه ولكن في المقابل ان ردت
ردا قويا نسبيا هذا يعني بانها امام ايام
من القتال على هذه الجبهه ان لم يكن اسوا
من ذلك ولهذا هي امام معضله حقيقيه هناك
من ينصح الحكومه الاسرائيليه من بين
الخبراء من بين الخبراء الامنيين في
اسرائيل حتى بالتريث في الرد الى ايام
اخرى ولكن حاليا يبدو ان هناك ضغط على هذه
الحكومه او الحكومه الامنيه التي تجتمع
بعد دقائق عمليا وهي حكومه غير مجربه من
الناحيه الامنيه معظم الوزراء لا علاقه
لهم بالموضوع لا يفقهون فيه شيئا تقريبا
شكرا لك من الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه
زياد حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه في القدس
اذا مشاهدينا توتر حدودي لم نشهده منذ
سنوات عشرات الصواريخ اطلقت من الاراضي
اللبنانيه باتجاه اسرائيل نعود لكيف بدا
طبعا مراسل العربيه قال ان عدد الصواريخ
كانت اربعه وثلاثين اسقط الجيش الاسرائيلي
25 منها عبر منظومه القبه الحديديه فيما
سقطت تسعه صواريخ بمناطق عده تسببت باصابه
ثلاثه اسرائيليين ردا على ذلك قصفت
اسرائيل لاطراف بلدتي القليل والمعلي في
قضاء سور جنوبي لبنان بالمدفعيه الثقيله
وفق الوكاله الوطنيه للاعلام وهي المنطقه
التي اطلقت منها صواريخ الكاتيوشي كما
لفتت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه الى اغلاق
المعابر من حيفا حتى الحدود مع لبنان
واغلاق المجال الجوي شمالي اسرائيل وفي
وقت نفد فيه ميليشيات حزب الله علاقتها
باطلاق هذه الصواريخ اشارت التقييمات
الامنيه الاسرائيليه الى وقوف فصائل
فلسطينيه خلف الامر مشدده على ان اطلاق
هكذا هجمات من الاراضي اللبنانيه لن يتم
الا بعلم من ميليشيات حزب الله
[موسيقى]
من تل ابيب ينضم الينا عبر زوم اللون
افيتار امن السابق في وزاره الدفاع سيد
اديتار ماذا نتوقع ان يكون الرد
الاسرائيلي على اطلاق هذه الصواريخ من
لبنان وهناك الان اجتماع للحكومه الامنيه
هذا السؤال المركزي لازم نكون بصراحه اذا
الغدر الاسرائيلي يكون قوي وفورا او مثلا
بمسلسل
اجباري وبجوز مش اليوم او بعد اسبوع وين
كل شيء متعلق بالصوره الاستخباريه ولكن
هذا الرد اين سيكون وماذا يمكن ان تكون
طبيعته سيد الون
الاسرائيليه وحمد الله لحد هلا ولا واحد
قتل في هذه
الهدف في هذه الهجوم من لبنان
السياسه الاسرائيليه المتعلقه بكم ظروف
اول شيء
اسرائيل حسب المعلومات الاستخباريه
راح توصل للجواب او لنتيجه من هو المسؤول
الحقيقي
[تصفيق]
من من لبنان
نحن سمعنا هلا انه حماس هي الحركه اللي
مسؤوله بغايه حزبالا سمينا على لوجان
المقومه وفي بجوز كمان
الطريق بيوصل لايران كمان
هذا اول
احداث في هذه النقطه بالذات لماذا هذا
التقييم الاسرائيلي اقرب الى الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وليس الى حزب الله هل هذا يدلل
بانها لا تريد اي تصعيد مع حزب الله في
لبنان
[موسيقى]
ونوصل الى نتيجه انه هي العنوان معناته
يكون تصعيد قبل حزبالنا بشكل محدود انا ما
بفكر انه اسرائيل بدها حرب كل الاشارات
تحكي انه اسرائيل بدها غاد قوي
وكثير بالوقت يعني مش بعيد ومش لمده طويله
ومش جبهه
بعيده كمان
اذيني هلا نحن شايفين انه قياده حماس
واقفه وراء الاحداث واذنه اسرائيل
بتحسب كل الحسابات بهذا الموضوع كمان
بالنسبه
نتاكد موضوع حماس هل سيكون الرد مثلا في
غزه ام اين
الامكانيات او احد من الامكانيات هي رادي
اسرائيلي ضد قياده حماس قياده حماس مش
معناته في قطاع غزه نحن بنعرف من زمان انه
كياديين حماس زي صلاح العوضي بجوله كمان
في مدن
سلاح العمومي
اجتماع للحكومه الامنيه بعد قليل هذه
الحكومه الامنيه ليس لديها اي تجربه امنيه
كيف يمكن ان تخرج بنتائج
صحيح القياده الاسرائيليه اليوم
مختلفه من القيادات الاسرائيليه في ثابت
بس اذني في ثلاث اربع شخصيات وكمان رئيس
نتنياهو نفسه لهم خبره طويله وهو صغير
الشباك السابق
التلاته اربعه دول ما وسائل منظمات
الامنيه كل ما بعد ثمانيه عشره هي القياده
الحقيقيه الامنيه داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه واذني نحن نشوف
الغداء الاسرائيلي اذا مش اليوم
شكرا من تل ابيبكن معي عبر زوم مستشار اني
سابق في وزاره الدفاع
في نشرتنا سنتابع بعد قليل
السعوديه وايران اتفاق للتمهيد لاعاده فتح
السفارات والقنصليات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اندلعت اشتباكات بين
الشرطه الفرنسيه ومتظاهرين رافضين لقانون
تمديد سن التقاعد في عدد من المدن
الفرنسيه وفي باريس عطله المتظاهرون حركه
الطريق واشعل النيران في الشوارع فيما
اطلقت الشرطه الغاز المسيل للدموع
لتفريقهم تاتي الاحتجاجات بعد يوم من فشل
الاجتماعي رئيسه الحكومه اليزابيث مع قاده
النقابات وهذه الصور هي من باريس حيث هذه
الاحتجاجات ما زالت مستمره وهناك بعض
المواجهات بين الشرطه والمحتاجين طبعا هذه
الاحتياجات خرجت منذ اسابيع ردا على سن
التقاعد او رفضا ايضا على موضوع رفع سن
التقاعد في فرنسا
ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
للشرطه الفرنسيه التي
تحاول ان تفرق المتظاهرين في باريس هذه
الاحتياجات ما زالت مستمره طيله هذا اليوم
في باريس وعدد من المدن الفرنسيه
وايضا هناك هذه المظاهرات ما زالت مستمره
منذ اسابيع حيث ان المتظاهرين مازالوا
متمسكين بمطلبهم تجاه موضوع سن التقاعد
بينما الحكومه والرئيس الفرنسي ايضا ما
زالوا مصرين على قرارهم حتى ان الرئيس
الفرنسي كان ذكر بان هذا القرار لن يعود
عنه حتى ولو افقده الكثير من شعبيته ما
زلنا نتابع هذه الصور من باريس
للمتظاهرين الذين ما يزال هنا متواجدين
الاعداد هي بالعشرات كما نتابع ومنذ قليل
ايضا في هذه الصوره كنا تابعنا تواجد كثيف
للشرطه الفرنسيه
المتواجده في الشوارع في باريس
لمواجهه هذه التظاهرات
مازلنا نتابع هذه الصور
وطبعا بعد قليل سيكون معنا زميلنا حسين
قنيبر ليطلعنا ايضا على هذا النهار الطويل
كيف كانت مجرياته واين تركزت هذه
المظاهرات وما هي الجهود التي تبذل لحل
هذه الازمه التي ما زالت مستمره منذ
اسابيع اذا زميلنا حسين قنيبر اصبح جاهزا
معنا حسين هل يمكن ان توجز لنا هذا النهار
طويل من الاحتجاجات في باريس ومختلف المدن
الفرنسيه
مساء الخير ميسون وانا اجيبك على سؤالك
نترك الكاميرا تتحرك لتنقل المشهد هنا في
بلاستيتالي لبلاس ديتالي ساحه ايطاليا
المشهد يبدو على شكل التالي مجموعات من
المتظاهرين لم تتفرق بعد هذا ما بقي منهم
الشرطه ستعمد لاحقا الى تفريقهم او تفريق
من بقي منهم على مستوى فرنسا تظاهر اليوم
حوالى مليونير شخص في كل فرنسا كما تقول
النقابات فيما تتحدث وزاره الداخليه عن
570 الف متظاهر فقط عبر فرنسا بكاملها من
بينهم 57 في باريس وحدها بحسب ارقام وزاره
الداخليه طبعا النقابات تتحدث دائما عن
بغداد اكبر من اعداد وزاره الداخليه خلال
المواجهات التي جرت هنا وفي مواقع اخرى من
العاصمه الفرنسيه جرح
154 شخصا
واوقفت الشرطه مئه واحد عشره شخصا عفوا
الجرحى من بين عناصر الشرطه هم 154
عنصرا
والموقفون من بين المتظاهرين هو عددهم
احد عشر
وطبعا
النقبات اعلنت كعادتها عند نهايه كل
تظاهرات تعلن عن موعد التحرك المقبل هي
اعلنت عن موعد التحرك المقبل الخميس في
الثالث عشر من هذا الشهر اي بعد اسبوع
وهذا التوقيت له دلالاته لانه ياتي قبل
يوم واحد على موعد الاصدار المجلس
الدستوري قراره بشان قانون رفع سن التقاعد
سيحدد المجلس الدستوري في الرابع عشر من
هذا الشهر فاذا كان رفع سن التقاعد مخالفا
ام موافقا للدستور هذا بعض من المشهد هنا
بالنسبه للمخارج بالنسبه للحلول المطروحه
المقبوله اقله من المتظاهرين ومن الحكومه
والرئيس الفرنسي هل يمكن ان تطلعنا عليها
هل هناك من حلول مطروحه الان
في الواقع حلول مختلفه باختلاف الفريق
الذي يرى كيف يمكن ان تكون النقابات لدى
لقاء ممثليها يوم امس برئيسه الحكومه
اليزابيث بورن طالبت باعتماد حل وحيد لا
يوجد غيره كما تقول النقبات وهو سحب قانون
رفع سن التقاعد فورا الحكومه تقول ان هذا
لا يمكن ان يكون حلا لان نظام التقاعد
يعاني من
عجز في ميزانيته سيبلغ هذا العجز 20
مليارا عام 2030 وبالتالي للحفاظ على نظام
التقاعد لجميع الفرنسيين لابد من ان يعمل
الفرنسيون عامين اضافيين تجنبا الانهيار
نظام التقاعد ماليا تقول الحكومه في كل
الاحوال المخارج لا تبدو متاحه المجلس
الدستوري اما ان يقبل قانون رفع سن
التقاعد كل بدوده يعتبره دستوريا او انه
يعتبر بعض بنوده دستوري والبعض الاخر غير
دستوري او ان يقبل بكل البنود يعتبرها
موافقه لبنود الدستور او يرفضه بكامله هذه
فرضيات كثيره لننتظر الى الرابع عشر من
هذا الشهر لنعرف كيف سيكون قرار المجلس
الدستوري سيسبق قراره تحرك جديد كما ذكرت
الخميس المقبل في الثالث عشر من هذا الشهر
تشاهدين ما يجري خلفي عناصر الشرطه
يحاصرون اعدادا من الشبان والشابات الذين
ما زالوا يتظاهرون هنا في ساحه كلاس
ديتالي
شكرا لك يا حسين مدير مكتب العربيه حسين
قنيبر كنت معي من باريس حيث اطلعتنا على
الصوره بشكل واضح على ما يجري الان في
شوارع باريس وايضا على الحلول التي من
الممكن ان تخرج فرنسا من هذه الازمه سنعود
الى بعض الصور ايضا
لاجتماع الحكومه الامنيه في اسرائيل التي
من المرتقب او يبدو بانه بدا هذا الاجتماع
من خلال هذه الصوره طبعا بحضور رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتانياهو طبعا هذه
الحكومه الامنيه تريد البحث عن
الرد على هجوم الصواريخ من لبنان على
اسرائيل الذي حصل خلال الساعات الماضيه
الان سننتقل الى الحرب في اوكرانيا
والعلاقات الاقتصاديه التي كانت ابرز
محاور زياره الرئيس الفرنسي امام الماكرون
ورئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل الى الصين
لقاءات
ماكرونج تركزت على ضروره احلال السلام على
توقيع اتفاقيات اقتصاديه كبرى نتابع
السياسه فن الممكن والممكن يحتاج الى بعض
الخطوات نزلا في سبيل فتح الباب امام
تواصل مباشر بعيدا عن التصريحات
والتصريحات المضاده والنتيجه لقاء في عز
تشنج العلاقات الدوليه بين معسكرى الشرق
والغرب
الرئيس الفرنسي سعى ليكون صوتا يوحد
اوروبا في بكين بحثا عن طريق السلام في
اوكرانيا رغم ان رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
التي ترافقه في هذه الزياره اطلقت بعض
التحذيرات شديده اللهجه في اتجاه بيكين
الاسبوع الماضي ساكن يعول كثيرا على صديق
الكريم
ليجلس الجميع الى طاوله المفاوضات من اجل
استعاده الاستقرار في المنطقه
اعلم انه يمكنني الاعتماد عليك لاعاده
روسيا الى رشدها والجميع الى طاوله
المفاوضات
الرئيس الصيني اظهر اتفاقه مع ماكرون
بخصوص اهميه السلام والاستقرار في اوروبا
مشيدا بتطور العلاقات بين بيكين وباريس
العلاقه بين باريس وبكين شهد تطورا
ايجابيا وثابتا ندعم استقلاليه اوروبا
الاستراتيجيه الصين وفرنسا تدعوان المجتمع
الدولي لتفادي اي تصعيد في الازمه
الاوكرانيه
زياره ماكرون المستمره لثلاثه ايام لها شق
اقتصادي مهم ايضا اكثر من خمسين رئيس شركه
فرنسيه بينها ايرباص وكهرباء فرنسا رافقوا
الرئيس الفرنسي لتوقيع عقود كبرى
رحله ماكرون الى الصين تاتي فيما التوترات
بشان تايوان في اوجها بعد لقاء رئيس مجلس
وبالاميركي ورئيسه تايوان غير ان ماكرون
فيما يبدو لا يهتم كثيرا بهذا الموضوع
بقدره اهتمامه بامن اوروبا
وعلاقات فرنسا الاقتصاديه بلال الوجداني
العربيه
[موسيقى]
وقعت السعوديه وايران بيان المشتركا عقب
اللقاء وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان والايراني حسين امير عبداللهيان
في العاصمه الصينيه بيكين وجاء في البيان
المشترك انه تم الاتفاق على بدء ترتيبات
اعاده فتح السفرتين والقنصليات وكذلك بحث
استئناف الرحلات الجويه وتسهيل منح
التاشيرات للمواطنين كما تم الاتفاق على
بحث استئناف تبادل زيارات المسؤولين ووفود
القطاع الخاص اضافه الى تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني الموقعه عام 2001 والتعاون
العام في المجالات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
والثقافيه والرياضيه الموقعه عام 1998 ودع
وزير الخارجيه السعودي نظيره الايراني
لزياره الرياض وعقد لقاء ثنائي واكد
القيام بكل ما يلزم لتحقيق امني واستقرار
المنطقه
اعلن جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي احباط
محاوله تسلل لمجموعه وصفها بانها تخريبيه
اوكرانيه الى اقليم بريانس داخل الاراضي
الروسيه وذكر جهاز الامن الفيدرالي ان
قوات حرس الحدود منع التسلل 20 من افراد
هذه المجموعه واطلقت النار باتجاههم
اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان مهمه
جميع التشكيلات العسكريه الروسيه تتمثل في
وقف القصف على دومباس وقال بوتين خلال
اجتماعه
انه من الضروري المضي قدما نحو تنفيذ
اهداف العمليه العسكريه ملتهما السلطات
الاوكرانيه بالتصرف بقسوه شديده ضد
المواطنين في
اما ميدانيا قال قائد مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه لن تتخلى عن
مدينه باخموت مضيفا انها حتى لو فعلت ذلك
فان هناك حاجه الى مزيد من الدعم من الجيش
النظامي قبل محاوله التقدم اكثر
يجب القول بوضوح ان العدو لن يذهب الى اي
مكان لقد نظموا دفاعاتهم اولا في خطوط
السكك الحديديه ثم في الابنيه السكنيه
الشاهقه على الجانب الغربي وعندما يغادرون
باخموت سنضغط على كل واحد منهم سيتخذون
بالتاكيد مواقع دفاعيه حول
لهذا السبب في رايي ليس هناك حديث في
الوقت الحالي عن اي هجوم الروسي
الذي يعرف
بالمنتقم دخل فعليا الخدمه في الجيش
الاوكراني قائد القوات الاوكرانيه
المشتركه وصف المنظومه بالجيده والفعاله
مضيفا ان الجنود العاملين على منظومات
افنجرز تدربوا على استخدامها في المانيا
السؤال ما هو هذا النظام اي افنجرز هو
نظام دفاعي جوي قصير المدى كما نتابع هنا
يملك ميزه اطلاق الصواريخ اثناء الحركه
ويعد عدو المروحيات الاول انشئ بواسطه
شركه بوينج وشكل عنصرا محوريا في هيكله
الدفاع الجويه المتقدم اذ يستخدم بشكل
اساسي لصد الاهداف الجويه منخفضه الارتفاع
كالمروحيات مثلا والمسيرات اضافه طبعا
للصواريخ والمقاتلات النظام يتم حمله على
مركبات هامفي متعدده المهام ويحوي ايضا
ثمانيه ص
موجهه بالاشعه تحت الحمراء يبلغ مدى
الصواريخ ما يقارب ثمانيه كيلو مترات كما
نتابع هنا تصل سرعتها الى نحو تسعه الاف
كيلومتر بالساعه هذه المنظومه تشمل كذلك
رشاشات ثقيله من عيار 12.7 مليمتر لزياده
كثافه النيران ونظاما الكترونيا للتحكم عن
بعد نظام افنجرز يتميز برادار امريكي
ثلاثي الابعاد متخصص بكشف الاهداف الجويه
على ارتفاعات المنخفضه ومتوسطه ويبلغ مداه
76 كيلو مترا بالاضافه الى ما سبق المنتقم
نظاما الكترونيا مضادا للتشويش ونظام
حمايه مضاده للصواريخ واخر لتعريف العدو
والصديق
ايضا هناك صمت تخرقه طقطقه مفاتيح او
اصابع كل حين وعزله تامه فيما وصف بل وصف
باكثر السجون شرا هذه بعض كوابيس سجناء
مروا في سجن لفورتوفو الروسي الذي يحتجز
فيه مراسل صحيفه وولز
بتهمه التجسس طبعا سجن
تم بناؤه على شكل حرف k كسجن عسكري شرقي
موسكو عام 1881
المنشاه تتكون من مئات الزنزانات الصغيره
المصممه بعنايه لجعل المعتقلين يشعرون
بعزله وانقطاع تام عن العالم الخارجي خلال
الحقبه السوفيتيه اصبح مكانا سيء السمعه
يساق اليه المنشقون وايضا غيرهم من
المساجين هناك ايضا يجري الحراس ممارسات
تهدف الى التاثير على الس نفسيا فهم
يمنعونهم من رؤيه او سماع اي شخص حتى
زملائهم من السجناء الاخرين صحيفه وللست
جون الاوضحت ان الحراس يقومون بدوريات
ويقرعون مفاتيحهم معا للاشاره الى ان
نزيلا تتم مرافقته لغرفه استجواب فيما
اخرون يطقطقون اصابعهم في الممرات ليصيبوا
المساجين بالجنون ووفق معتقلين سابقين من
المحتمل ان يكون مراسل الصحيفه في الحجر
الصحيح حاليا وهو اجراء يستمر تقريبا
اسبوعين للكشف عن التهاب الكبد وامراض
اخرى
[موسيقى]
رد صيني لم يتاخر على استقبال رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي لرئيسه التايوان وان كان
يصب في خانه الاستفزاز فقط حيث اقتربت
حامله طائرات صينيه من الجزيره واكدت انها
رصدت حامله الطائرات وثلاثه سفن حربيه
صينيه وهي تجري تدريبات على بعد نحو 370
كيلومترا من سواحل تايوان الشرقيه واضافت
ان القوات المسلحه رقبه الوضع وكلفت طائره
من قوه الدوريه الجويه القتاليه وسفن
البحريه وانظمه الصواريخ الارضيه بالرد
على هذه الانشطه
قال خفر السواحل اليابانيه انه يبحث عن
طائره هليكوبتر تابعه للجيش بعد اختفائها
قباله جزيره في جنوب اليابان واضاف خفر
السواحل الياباني ان المروحيه من طراز يو
اتش بلاك هوك تابعه لقوات الدفاع الذاتيه
البريه اختفت من على الرادار بالقرب من
جزيره مياكو من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء
الياباني
ان الاولويه للحفاظيه على ارواح المفقودين
[موسيقى]
والان الى تيك توك فلم تمنع التهديدات
والمحاولات الامريكيه لحظر تيك توك من
تحقيق التطبيق الصيني مكاسب اعلانيه واين
داخل الولايات المتحده نفسها
كشفت في تقرير لها عن ان تيك توك حقق
ارباحا كبيره من خلال اعلانات لصالح شركات
امريكيه كبرى مضيفه ان الاعلان على تطبيق
تيك توك الصيني في الولايات المتحده انما
بنسبه
11% خلال شهر مارس وحده وهو ارتفاع قياسي
في ظل ازمه حاليه ابرز الشركات المعلنه
على تيك توك كانت بيبسي امازون وابل وفقا
لبيانات من مجموعه تحليل التطبيقات سنسر
تاور زياده الاعلانات لم يكن المكسبه
الوحيده تيك توك بل ووفقا للتحليلات فان
الاصرار والرغبه على الاعلام من خلال
التطبيق ارتفع لدى المعلنين داخل المؤسسات
والشركات الكبرى في امريكا ومع ذلك دفعت
الضجه السياسيه ضد تيك توك بعض العلامات
التجاريه الى وضع خطط طوارئ مثل نقل
الانفاق الاعلاني الى منصات منافسه مثل
متى وجوجل استعدادا لحظر امريكيين محتمل
[موسيقى]
قبل ان اتوقف مع فصل لنذكر هذا الخبر
العاجل اكسيوس تقول عن مسؤول اسرائيلي بان
اسرائيل تستعد لرد قاسم على حماس في غزه
اذا حسب اكسيوس ونقله عن مسؤول اسرائيلي
بان اسرائيل تستعد لرد قاسم على غزه ايضا
حسب اكسيوس وايضا عن هذا المسؤول
الاسرائيلي تقول بانهم يبحثون طبيعه الرد
المناسب على اطلاق صواريخ من لبنان سنتوقف
بعد قليل
وسنتابع في تصريح
درامي ستورميدان يستقول ترامب لا يستحق
السجن بسبب قضيتي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت الممثله الاباحيه
ستورميدانيا الشخصيه الابرز في محاكمه
ترامب انها لا تعتقد ان الرئيس السابق
يستحق السجن في قضيتها بدورهم استدعى
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب مدعيا عاما
سابقا في منهاتا ساهم في اطلاق قضيه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ومنذ
خروجه من المحكمه في نيويورك توعد متهميه
بالانتقام غير ان احدى الوجهات الانتقاميه
طريقها مسدود وهي طلبه من الجمهوريين
تقليل التمويل الموجه لوزاره العدل ومكتب
التحقيقات الاتحادي لحين عودتهما الى
رشدهما وفق تعبيره بدايه سلطتاء القانون
الاتحاديه غير مسؤولتين عن توجيه التهم
الجنائيه اليه وانما المدعي العام في
منهات
اما ثاني العقبات فهي رفض متوقع من
الكونجرس الاقتراح ترامب مع سيطره
الديمقراطيين على مجلس الشيوخ فالجمهوريون
يمسكون بدفه مجلس النواب فقط مكتب تحقيقات
الاتحاديه امتنع عن التعليق على تصريحات
ترامب فيما لم ترد وزاره العدل على طلب
للتعليق
[موسيقى]
قابليه الترشح للرئاسه وسيد للبيت الابيض
مودان تساؤلات رماديه بالمجهوله الاجوبه
تقطع حتى اللحظه للتفسير والتاويلات
فامكانيه اكمال رحله التنفس للعوده للبيت
الابيض باتت موضعه تساؤل ما هو مصير
دونالد ترامب السياسي هل لا يزال بامكانه
الترشح للرئاسه وهل يستطيع البقاء في
البيت الابيض ان ادين محللون وصفوا الازمه
الحاليه
بالدستوريه من اعلى مستوى حتى اكبر من
قضيه ووتر غيت وفق تعبيرهم حاليا لا يوجد
موانع لاستكمال حمله الرئاسيه او المشاركه
وحتى الفوز في الانتخابات كونه لا يزال
غير مدان فالمحاكمه لا تخرجه تلقائيا من
حمله الرئاسه على الاقل قانونيا اما شعبيا
فيمكن ان تضر التحقيقات والجلسات بحظوظه
في الفوز او قد تكون دعايه ناجحه اما ثاني
التساؤلات هل يحق ان يصبح رئيسا في حاله
الادانه اصدار حكم سواء البراءه او
الادانه قد يتاخر الى ما بعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه المقبله والمقرره طبعا
في نوفمبر 202 حينها اذا ادينا ترامب
سيواجه خيار الذهاب الى السجن الى السجن
او دفع غرامه او الحصول على حكم مع وقف
التنفيذ وبالتالي يصبح اول رئيس امريكي
يتعرض للادانه او الحكم بالسجن لكن هذا لا
يعني بالضروره خروجه تلقائيا من سباق
الرئاسه بمجرد الادانه او انه سيترك
المكتبه البيضاوي في حال صدر الحكم بعد
فوزه في الانتخابات مجله نفت وجود اجابه
واضحه لذلك في الدستور الامريكي فهو لا
فقره تمنع صراحه انتخاب رئيس مدن
بجريمه او تمنع انتخاب رئيس وهو داخل
السجن كما ان انتخاب رئيس لا يلغي التهم
المرفوعه ضده
ولا يخرجه من السجن في حال كان دخله قبل
الانتخابات
امتثال اول رئيس امريكي امام القضاء
رافقته موجه من الاراء المتضاربه حول
تاثير القضيه على ترامب المترشح
الا ان القصه التي تروي اصوله لهذه
المرحله باتت واحده وبدايتها كانت ذات يوم
من يوليو عام 2006 مع الممثله الاباحيه
ستورميدانينز لقاء في ملعب جولف تلاته
صوره تذكاريه ثم دعوه للعشاء العنوان لم
يكن مطعما شهيرا بل غرفه فندق في بحيره
تاهو اللقاء الحميمي دام ثلاث ساعات ولم
يكن له ما بعده دانييلز لم ترضى بثمن لا
يتناسب مع وزن الزبون الى ان اثمرت
المفاوضات ب 130 الف دولار دفعها مايكل
كوهن مقابل دفن السر ومصدر الاموال يبقى
مقصد القضيب ترامب صار رئيسا ولم يعد ينفع
مع دانييلز مال ولا تهديد المواجهه دخلت
المحاكم وكل ما يسعى اليه الدفاع ترامب
الان هو تاجيل الحكم الى ما بعد
الانتخابات للقضاء راي اخر مدعما حاتم
العام ينوي غلق القضيه قبل الانتخابات
وهنا يدخل ترامب نفقا بمخرجين براءه او
حتى ادانه دون ايداع قد يقوده للبيت
الابيض ومصير اخر تفرضه ادانه مع ايداع
الفوري في السجن وهنا نهايه طموحاته
السياسيه
من وعشنطن ينضم اليرغم مراسل العربيه اهلا
بك معنا ما زالت
هي التي تتصدر الاخبار هناك مقابله
تلفزيونيه معها بعد ساعات قليله واليوم
هذا التصريح من منها بانه لا يستحق السجن
في قضيتها ولكن في القضايا الاخرى كيف
يمكن ان نفهم هذه التصريحات
مع الاسف اننا نفهم ان هذه الممثله
الاباحيه فاصبحت خبيره قانونيه وما فعلته
قناه فوكس هي انها وزعت بعض المقتطفات من
هذه المقابله وهناك مقتطف طوله دقيقه
تقريبا وهي تحاول ان تروج
للحظه التي يتم فيها بث هذا البرنامج
بالفعل كما ذكرتي قالت ان الرئيس السابق
لا يجب ان يوضع في السجن بسبب القضيه
المرفوعه ضده في نيويورك لكنها اشارت الى
ان هناك قضايا اكثر خطوره وربما بسبب
قضايا مثل قضيه التمرد والهجوم على
الكونجرس هي قضايا اكثر اهميه من قضيتها
ودفع الاموال لها بالنسبه ايضا لموضوع
الاستطلاعات يبدو بانه الاستطلاع الاخير
او هذه القضيه بالذات بدات مفعلها بنتائج
الاستطلاعات ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول
الاستطلاع الاخير بالنسبه للرئيس ترامب
وبايدن
هذا موضوع مهم جدا ميسون ما حدث هو انه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه كان يبدو الرئيس
الحالي جو بايدن على الرغم من تراجع
شعبيته انه سوف يفوز في الانتخابات العامه
لو كانت هذه الانتخابات العامه بينه وبين
دونالد ترامب ولكن في الايام الخمسه
الماضيه اي منذ ان بدات قضيه الادانه يوم
الخميس الماضي ثم مثول الرئيس السابق دون
ترامب امام المحكمه تغيرت الاستطلاعات
اقله بشان مؤسسه واحده او اثنتان وهي تؤكد
الان ان دونالد ترامب لو ترشح في هذه
الانتخابات ضد بايدن فان ترامب سوف ينتصر
والفارق بينهما هو اثنان في المئه بالنسبه
ايضا للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب البعض
يعتبر بان هذه القضيه اصبحت دستوريه اذا
كان يحق له
الترشح اذا ادين وهو رئيس للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ايضا
هل حقيقه اصبحت قضيه دستوريه اكثر من
موضوع ووتر غيت
باختصار لو سمحت
موضوع ترامب لا يبدو حتى الان على انه جدي
على المستوى الدستوري كل القضايا التي هو
متهم فيها لا ترقى الى ما يصفه الدستور
الامريكي وخصوصا ان اي تهمه من الاتهامات
المواجهه له طريقه لان تكون جريمه كبرى
والجريمه الكبرى هي التي تمنعه من الترشح
او من شغل البيت الابيض شكرا لك من واشنطن
مراسل العربيه
لكنهن قد يطحن بعرش واحد من اقوى رجال
العالم في لحظات ترامب في مازق مع قصصه
الغراميه السابقه
نجمه مجله
تقول انها تلقت 150 الف دولار مقابل صمتها
عن علاقه غراميه
ومن عالم الافلام الاباحيه خرجت ستورمي
دانيالز لتدعي انها تلقت 130 الف دولار
لاخفاء علاقه جنسيه
فهل صحيح ان ترامب كان زيرا نساء ولديه
الكثير من القصص هذا ما تحقق فيه المحكمه
وما قد يحدد مستقبل ترامب السياسي
[موسيقى]
كره ابدا ان شيئا كهذا يمكن ان يحدث في
امريكا ولم اعتقد ابدا انه يمكن ان يحدث
الجريمه الوحيده التي ارتكبتها هي الدفاع
بلا خوف عن امتنا من اولئك الذين يسعون
الى تدميرها
تجسست الديمقراطيون على حملته تذكر ذلك
لقد هاجموني بتهم من التحقيقات الاحتياليه
زوجه ترامب عارضه الازياء السابقه ميلانيا
لا يبدو انها سعيده بقصص زوجها مع النساء
وان كانت غير مثبته في المحكمه حتى اللحظه
غيرتها وربما اشياء اخرى دفعتها للاختفاء
عن الاضواء وعدم الظهور بجانب زوجها في
محنته الحاليه
لوحدها البنت سر ابيها
ابنه ترامب المدلله تواصل الدفاع عن
والدها وتنفي عنه عده تهم منها التحرش
الجنسي يواجه ترامب 34 تهمه نفاها كلها في
محكمه
منها تهم وفساد ومنها تهم احتيال ونساء قد
يكون كيدهن سببا في وضع اقوى رجال العالم
خلف القضبان
[موسيقى]
اكدت الجهات المعنيه في المسجد الحرامي
مكه المكرمه على ضروره الالتزام المعتبرين
المعتمرين والزوار والمصلين بخطه التفويج
والحشود والابتعاد عن مواطن التزحم واشددت
على اهميه الالتزام بالارشادات عند
الابواب والمطاف والمسعى والطرق المؤديه
الى الحرم والتزام خطه التفويج والحشود
التي وضعتها الجهات المعنيه في الحرم
المكي
[موسيقى]
توقعت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان ترفع حالات
بل ترفع حالات الطوارئ المرتبطه بفيروس
كورونا هذا العام
ولما يحدد المدير العام للمنظمه اطارا
زمنيا محددا الا ان المنظمه ستعقد
اجتماعنا للجنه الخبراء فيما يلقادم
ونعود مشاهدينا قليلا لنتابع هذه الصور من
شوارع باريس حيث المتظاهرون ما زالوا في
شوارع باريس طبعا هذه التظاهرات ما زالت
مستمره منذ اسابيع تنديدا
بقانون سن التقاعد
وايضا ستستمر هذه المظاهرات حتى الاسبوع
المقبل وكانت شهدت شوارع باريس اشتباكات
بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
والمحتجين ضد هذا القانون قانون التقاعد
في باريس الذي تصر عليه الحكومه الفرنسيه
والرئيس الفرنسي
بينما يصر المتظاهرون على رفضها نستمع الى
الصوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عداد القتلى رفيق الحروب والكوارث المؤلم
الا ان معاناه مخلوقات اخرى غير البشر
تبقى صعبه التحديد بالعاده في الحروب
نفسها فالمعارك تسفر على ملايين الضحايا
الصامتين كالعمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا مثلا التي تدفع الدلافين في
البحر الاسود للانقراض دراسه حديثه توصلت
الى نفوق عشرات الالاف من الحيتان في
منطقه
واوكرانيا واوضحت الدراسه ان مراقبه نفوق
بعض الحيوانات صعب والسبب يعود لاولويه
الخسائر البشريه وصعوبه اجراء بحث علمي
اثناء الحرب
ثوب ازهار الكرز ارتدته العاصمه اليابانيه
طوكيو مبكرا هذا العام اي من منتصف مارس
تقريبا حله ملونات تتزين بها مناطق مختلفه
وتصبح ديكورات وخلفيات منتظره من الكثيرين
للتصوير حيث يتدفق المواطنون والسياح من
كل اصقع العالم لرؤيه اشجار الكرز التي
تفتح الزهورها بشكل كامل سواء مشيا على
الاقدام او في القطارات ظهور الكرز مشهد
موحد ولكن بلونين الابيض والزهري
وثقت صور جويه اثار الدمار الذي خلفه
اعصار ضرب جنوب شرق ولايات سامي السوري
جنوب الشرقيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حيث تسبب الاعصار بمقتل خمسه اشخاص
وتضرروا سبعه
[موسيقى]
نشره التاسعه هذا المساء انتهت نذكر
بالعناوين
هجوم صاروخيه من لبنان على اسرائيل
نتنياهو يحمل حماس المسؤوليه ويبحثوا مع
الجيش طريقه الرد
[موسيقى]
اثنان يدعو المجتمع الدولي لوقف اي تصعيد
اسرائيلي ويبدي استعداده للتهدئه عبر
اليونيفل
[تصفيق]
يا منسخن في فرنسا الاحتجاجات تتحول
الاشتباكات وعمليات التخريب ردا على قانون
التقاعد
ورغم دعوات حظر تيك توك يحقق ارباحا
اعلانيه عاليه من كبرى شركات في امريكا
[موسيقى]
التاسع هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبار
العربيه دائما مستمره والان مع نشره
360 والزميله راويه مثلا لدينا من ملفات
راويه اهلا بك ميسون طبعا السؤال الابرز
الان كيف
يعني اين تحديدا سيكون الرد الاسرائيلي
على الهجوم الصاروخي الذي تعرضت له
الاحتجاجات
الباريسيه وفي عده مناطق ايضا مستمره على
قانون التقاعد تابعينا